for example the other night I was
watching the presidential debate yeah I
was watching the presidential debate and
I was curious what would happen if I had
the info button so I hit the info button
it said brought to you by Air Canada
visit our website for one way November
fair I was watching MacGyver
I was watching MacGyver yeah there's a
new MacGyver yeah and then I hit the
button and it said reboot of the 90
series jerry-rigged together from duct
tape chewing gum and Hollywood being out
of idea yeah
flipping around I came across PC span
there was c-span yeah yeah and then I
hit the button and it said there's a
good Seinfeld rerun two channels out oh
that is helpful yeah and I did it was a
good one yeah then I was watching bar
rescued you know this show bar rescue
why I am aware of it yeah bar rescue and
I was watching that for a bit and then I
hit the button it said tonight a
shrieking middle-aged man bullies of
failing tiki bar into serving pizza
bagels Dancing with the Stars I was
watching Dancing with the Stars okay
there's Vanilla Ice I think yeah do we
know ice yeah and then I hit the button
and it said to be specific the stars of
February through May of 1991
watching The Real Housewives of New
Jersey yeah and then I hit the button
and it said sentient bags of dermal
fillers throw cosmos at each other until
one of them goes to jail NCIS I was
watching NCIS yeah and then I hit the
button it said this text is large
because if you're watching this you're
old in this one a scary crime gets
solved don't worry they can't get you
all that is important then they get me
and then finally I was watching Antiques
Roadshow yeah Antiques Roadshow and then
I hit the button and it said greedy
creeps cash in after burglarizing their
grandparents
[Applause]
on the screen at my speech
[Applause]
you